[Music]
I started to give talks and panels about
the problems that I saw in the faith
then there was a sense of wait wait
let's let's think about whether this is
the right time to talk about these
issues I've started to reevaluate that
and consider that maybe I was not
um fully understanding uh the
fundamental values and principles of the
modern left and it is also the case that
Islam treats Innovation within the faith
differently than than other religions I
think it is more intolerant one of those
ways in which I think Islam is different
unique unique in the main main religions
of the world is that it is very
political the higher the percentage of
Muslims
in your locality the more
um the more that this deep you know this
this blasphemy prohibition becomes
actual de facto law
thank you
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the
road from the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our terrific
guest today is a writer and the
co-founder of ex-muslims for North
America Sarah hey to welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me here
guys it's great to have you it's a
pleasure to speak with you I mentioned
to you before that one of the reasons we
so wanted to talk to you is you wrote a
piece after the Salman Rushdie attempted
murder that was so powerful and
articulated things that I'd never really
heard said in that way which we're going
to talk about before we get into that
though tell our audience who may not be
familiar with who you are who are you
what's been your journey through life
how do you find yourself sitting here
talking to us
well
I was born in Pakistan
States I my parents came to America when
I was about eight years old so that
process of becoming an immigrant and
acclimating to a new country learning
language all of that like that's a big
part of my personal history my son you
know my whole self-narrative
um and you know I was raised in a Muslim
family
and so that was
um at first
a sense of like you know self-identity
in this new place it gave me kind of a
grounding of who I was in this new place
and then
um over time as I started to think about
it
um religion started to make less and
less sense
um and so when I was about I want to say
15 years old I left the faith I left
Islam
and it caused many problems
um and you know in my family in my
personal life and for many years I felt
very alone with this and very burdened
by this I knew many people who had left
religion who were atheists from
Christian backgrounds from you know many
Jews who were actually they were
practicing they would call themselves
practicing Jews but not actually believe
in a god which I thought was really
interesting but I had never known anyone
like me um and for those who might not
be aware and I'm sure I'm sure that many
of the people in your audience do know
but there's a very extreme apostasy
stigma
um in in Islam and really just a huge uh
stigma against dissent religious descent
in general it's not really something
that's it's not exactly a tolerant
religion
um when it comes to freedom of speech
from of thought the freedom to leave of
faith
um so
this was you know it was a very
isolating uh experience for me to to
leave the faith
um and then one day when I would after I
had you know graduated college and
everything I found another ex-muslim uh
we were he you know he was very
fascinated with with the idea of maybe
starting something and so we started uh
an organization called ex-muslims of
North America that exists to advocate
for for the rights of ex-muslims um for
the right to life in some parts of the
world where apostasy is a crime
punishable by death but also just the
social stigma and ostracism and
sometimes pretty severe abuse that
ex-muslims go through
um so it's really just a an organization
founded on secular principles but also
just to normalize religious dissent
that's sort of well we're orienting
ourselves around and specifically
focusing on Islam um and the problems
within the Muslim Community
um so that's how
I spent a long time
and in my role as a co-founder of this
new organization an activist
organization I started to
give talks and panels about the problems
that I saw in the faith mostly within an
audience that was
very friendly to me other atheists
humanists secularists free thinkers that
sort of thing
um and yet even even in that audience I
I felt as if I was saying something
nobody wanted to really hear
um really yeah which is to say that
they were on my page when it came to
religion is bad but when I started to
talk about specifically what's going on
with Islam or why in some cases Islam
might be worse you know or treat there
might be specific challenges to this
Faith uh then there was a sense of wait
wait let's let's think about whether
this is the right time to talk about
these issues Muslims are going through
you know bigotry and and you know
they're not accepted in the west we need
to think about whether this is the right
you know time and place to be to be
talking about these things or in such a
way so I felt a very powerful pressure
even within a community that I should
have been perfectly welcomed in
um to to not really
Target that my my criticism so directly
against the religious Faith itself
um to really start Focus things on focus
on extremists
who are extreme and they should be more
like moderate Muslims who are peaceful
and happy and the sort of
what I called
language you know happy liberal language
that focuses on everybody most people
are very good and kind and wonderful and
there's some extremists who are just
messing it all up and that's true but we
need to talk about what ideology really
means because you can be a very good
person and if you have an ideology that
tells you this is the good thing to do
you will do that thing
um and so we need to be thinking about
what religions and ideologies are
telling people are good and right things
to do because then these good and
compassionate and lovely people uh start
to do some things that are probably not
so great
um so I you know I I felt unwelcome
within this community and
and very unwelcome actually in the
broader Progressive space and that was
very shocking and alarming to me I think
a lot of the people who end up in the
heterodoc space
one way or another had this Awakening is
this moment of like wait this is not how
it's supposed to be you're supposed to
be agreeing with me you're supposed to
be on my side I'm bringing up issues
that you care about the equality between
men and women you know no no uh
persecution of religious minorities you
agree with all this stuff science reason
all those that you agree with it you
should be on my side and then to find
that you are actually not very welcome
um and in fact seen as suspicious
as someone who is uh going to bring in
some toxic attitudes
um and and
it was heartbreaking you know at at
first really when I because I was a good
good little Progressive liberals but
these were values that meant a lot to me
and they were a big part of why I left
religion and you know why I how I saw
myself as a person and to see this to
see myself being rejected even though in
principle I shouldn't have been
um it was like being you know kicked out
again because I had I left my community
of origin my religious community and
then again to feel that way
um on this this political
um you know tribe that I I felt very
close to I have a few questions but let
let's start with one you mentioned that
in that sort of liberal space or the
atheist space or whatever it was people
would say that you shouldn't talk about
Islam specifically because Muslims are
under a lot of pressure and so on do you
think that's that is the real reason or
do you think there's something
underneath all of that because I often
feel I don't know if it's the same in
America but in the UK where we live
quite often people are they will use
that excuse but what they're actually
thinking is this is a dangerous thing to
talk about
yeah definitely well
I think there's multiple motivations
that are you know running in the
background
which is why the whole thing is so
confusing you know why you're not
supposed to be behaving this way so why
are you being behaving this way
um I think the fear element is certainly
real and I think it is more it is more
important
um than than some of the other
ideological factors even just the sense
of like I don't wanna I don't wanna get
in trouble I don't want to put my kids
you know in danger I don't want to put
my co-workers in danger by you know
publishing this thing or saying this
thing
um you know I found when I when I would
go to to give talks
um that you know if I was on a panel or
something like that
the other speakers would be very nervous
to sort of be around me to share a space
with me
um and there were times where people I I
know that they felt very insecure just
in being in the same presence as as
someone like me and so they would ask
for like lots and lots of Security even
more security than perhaps I would have
asked for so multiple times I found
myself in the position of feeling as if
you know I was a problem because I was
introducing this level of
um you know risk that everybody else had
now to take on to and I think
um that's always running in the
background and we don't want to feel
like fearful people we don't want to
feel like the kind of person that is run
by
you know cowardly motivations
so then we have to make up something
else to justify why we're behaving in a
cowardly way and I think a lot of the
sort of woke rhetoric serves that
function
um but to fully answer your question I
think it's also the case that
I think I misunderstood what
the principles of the progressive left
might be
um tell us about that yeah so I
I mean there's all this conversation
about like what is woke what does this
mean and people struggle to you know
what sorry to interrupt you in the
middle of answering a question you know
what's funny is Francis and I when we
started trigonometry we talked about
wokeness a lot because it was affecting
our industry of comedy and then the more
we looked at Society the more we saw
there was having an impact we I've never
said a word to you about workness we
didn't talk about it before we started
we were interested in talking to you
about your concerns about Islam and so
on and yet wokeness comes up right
straight away why is that
well I think it is
um
part of the maybe it's not new at all
but I think that there is a difference
between what I saw as
Progressive ideology
um liberal ideology I don't know if that
makes sense if I'm a UK perspective with
the Liberals and leftists and
progressives are a little different but
I have always called myself a liberal
and I meant as someone on the left who
believes in freedom of speech freedom of
thought freedom of Association and
equality and all this stuff to your
right wing
well um you know it's interesting so it
we keep running against
um you know many people in the heterodox
space they just well you're supposed
everyone was supposed to behave this way
and they react so strongly to something
I said that they should not have and so
you have this conversation of the left
has lost its principles it's lost its
way and I think I
made a lot of the same noises for a long
time
um and I think that I've started to
reevaluate that and consider that maybe
I was not
um fully understanding uh the
fundamental values and principles of the
Modern Life
um
in that I don't think the governing
principles are Enlightenment values
and I don't know if they have been that
way for a long time
I think that they're you know I think
that
the political left
uh was changed quite a bit with its
encounter with you know socialism and
socialist thinking
and if I had to
if I had to put into words what
I think drives a modern left now or or
what its philosophy might be I think I
would
I think I would call it
kind of New Age like therapeutic radical
egalitarianism so this this idea that we
are all equal which is so you know and
we should be equal economically legal
which would be the Socialist thing but
the emphasis here is not so much on
economics although they still care about
that
um but on um social equality
on equal moral affirmation and dignity
you know there's a there's a there's
quite a bit of therapeutic language
wrapped up in all of this
um this this sense of I I have uh
myself and myself deserves to be
validated my choices deserve to be
validated they deserve to be affirmed
um and it focuses quite a bit on this
um there's a B I think it focuses uh so
much on the social and the personal
because this orientation has shifted
um and if you are a good little good
liberal now you're a like you're white
you're white and wealthy or whatever
you're doing well you have a you have a
nice job somewhere and you feel
um compelled to to show the world that
you're a good person well what are you
going to do now
um in this in this new modern left you
might focus on
you know pushing up others you know
getting them to to where you are and I
think that that's why we see so much of
this signaling
um from
various powerful people you know
literally sometimes kneeling at the at
the feet of of uh sacred people
marginalized people
um lifting them up and in that act also
talking is lifting themselves up and you
know showing how morally Superior they
are uh to in fact work towards this
social egalitarianism
it's interesting that you say that
because with this Progressive culture
you're a woman of color you should have
been embraced and celebrated and lifted
up
I should have been right
I mean there's so much of this it
doesn't make sense so many people who
who
you know talk about how you know
wokeness or whatever is going on
um impacts various communities are
people of color people of various sexual
orientations and it doesn't seem to
matter so I think there is a way in
which you can cancel out your your
um
a demographic you know affiliations
um if you show yourself
um as being someone who's not committed
to that project of of radical
egalitarianism so let's move on to Islam
and you you've been very critical of
Islam well what are your main criticisms
of it as a religion and the ideology in
particular
yeah I mean I've many criticisms of it
so I'm I'm an atheist so I have the
general you know atheist stance on you
know logical contradictions and and all
that
um when it comes to belief in general
and maybe Revelation and the problem of
evil and all of that
um I'm very motivated by by those
arguments or uh had been when I when I
left the religion
um
but then uh you know
lots of things are wrong and you know we
believe lots of wrong things all the
time
some things are wrong and not so quite
harmful because they're not really
affecting a lot of people like maybe I
believe in like astrology and the way
that it impacts me is that I wear my you
know like Sagittarius whatever Virgo you
know necklace and you know maybe I have
beads of various rocks what do they I
don't know what they mean or but believe
what people tend to have things like
that and I I think it gives me some kind
of magical power that's a wrong belief
uh that's a wrong belief that doesn't
really impact our world in a way that I
would consider very serious so from the
perspective of prioritizing our our what
we what we choose to address as a
society maybe I think less about uh
astrology girls on Twitter and more
about uh what
conservative Muslims are saying about
what should be true in this world what
Justice looks like
um what eventually should be the fate of
the world
and they see they see themselves as part
of a political project
to see this Vision carried out
and I think those ideas matter and they
affect us in the real world and so we
should be talking about it you know in
the you guys are from you know a place
which has a higher percentage of Muslims
Americans sometimes struggle with it
because we know about
the fringes we know about terrorism
but the Muslim Community here is far
more liberal far more well like uh
well integrated well integrated
[Music]
um and I think some of that is just due
to the the way that America brings in
immigrants and how it chooses to to one
sort the people so the filter is
different but also what when you get
here you have to survive in different
modes in America and so I think that
produces a kind of a different
population we see that on our Muslims
they're not as extreme but we still we
do have religious pockets
in the UK you guys see how well you have
a high percentage of Muslims a lot of
them are not well integrated and you see
that playing out in schools in
communities
um and I think that that's we have to be
able to talk about this honestly and we
have to be able to talk about what's
motivating the belief not just the fact
that it's bad that you know Muslims are
you know treating unwelcome to to gay
people or whatever you know in a
specific Locale that is bad but what's
motivating it why do they believe that
this is the right thing to do because
they're not
bad people like like what we said
they're not bad people they think that
what they're doing is right so we have
to be able to meet them at that
intellectual level and tell them you
know convince them persuade them why it
isn't right
this episode is brought to you by better
help Constantine what's the best thing
about having this episode sponsored by
betterhelp in my country mental health
is something that you have before you
start drinking thankfully we'll start
drinking at breakfast so we have no
problem really yes our slogan is drink
breakfast vodka and become real men okay
but if you do want to feel better inside
and out then maybe you should try better
help I have been doing therapy for over
a year and it has really helped me
understand myself better and become far
more effective in both my work and my
personal life I always knew you were not
real men pass me the Vodka therapy has
helped me transform myself so that I
take responsibility for my behavior and
my attitude you can't achieve your
dreams if you don't think you deserve to
every shot you drink make you feel
stronger what is problem and the great
thing about betterhelp is that it's all
online and they can connect you with a
licensed therapist who can work with you
so that you can achieve your goals it
takes a few minutes to set up and it can
fit around your schedule I will never
forget my first love Olga orgasmachenko
and the Beautiful relationship that
could have been any if it's not working
for you with a particular therapist then
you can always switch at no extra charge
I am doomed to become Russian poet
discover your potential with better help
visit
betterhelp.com
trigger today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trigger
I have run out of breakfast Vodka it's
time for lunchtime Brandy
we've talked about the intolerance of
gay people and you've spoken a lot about
Islam's relationship with women and how
women are treated differently under
Islam for people like myself who may not
be aware of it or understand it can you
just break it down for us what does that
actually mean
well um so to start with the the women's
element so Islam is a sexist religion
many of the you know all the religions
are they have this role they see is the
right role of man and the right role of
women and they are traditional roles so
you what what would you expect would be
the role of man and what you would
expect to be the role of women
um and because it is a religious belief
and it is not really something you can
negotiate it is really hard to move past
uh what the religion might prescribe
um and as a consequence you see in the
Muslim throughout the Muslim world you
see women's rights are you know uh far
some of the worst countries in the world
for women are Muslim majority countries
like let me put it that way so this is a
this is a big problem
um and it is also the case that
Islam treats Innovation within the faith
differently than than other religions I
think it is more intolerant
um because of specific verses and
scriptures and we won't get into all of
that but I think it is less accepting of
evolution in in belief
um and I think you see the consequences
of that because Muslims are socially
rigid um when they are socially
conservative they are rigid in their
beliefs and it's very hard to get them
to to budge
um and I think that is a consequence
also of the belief itself
uh there are
elements of uh I guess the differences
between Islam and Christianity that I
feel foreign to Christians so I have to
sort of explain and break it down a
little bit but one of those ways in
which I think Islam is different unique
unique in the main main religions of the
world is that it is very political
um it is innately political you can't
really separate this Muhammad was
a politician a Statesman as well as a
religious leader you know that's within
the accepted you know scriptures and
texts and that's why you see such a
thing like Islamic States you know um
and you see a drive and a push towards
more a more unified approach to religion
and and
governance and politics so this makes
the conversation around democracy around
human rights around just like secularism
the separation of mosque and state in
this case
to be very tricky to be very difficult
and it is harder to convince Muslim
majority populations to shift in that
direction so we we see different
challenges and in Muslim majority of
countries when it comes to advancing
democracy advancing secularism uh in in
particular
so I think that you know those things
matter the differences in the faith
matter and in some ways it is of course
because the faith is different in some
ways it might be better suited for some
challenges of the modern world I think
some Muslims would say that
um and they might have a point in you
know a place or two and then in some
ways it is definitely not meeting those
challenges I think the the difficulty
with us in the West
is how do we how do we maintain
tolerance you know religious tolerance
our ideals of religious tolerance and
also keep in mind that we should be
allowed to criticize ideas we should be
allowed to uh make people feel
uncomfortable you know
um and then this rubs the modern you
know liberal left in a very wrong way
they they feel as if you know this is a
very
self-esteem oriented Ideology Now and to
to say that well I'm going to criticize
Islam I'm going to
Target its ideology directly I'm going
to bring up versus and I'm gonna
challenge Muslims around me to to you
know
explain or move in their you know in
their religious beliefs or to abandon
them as I did
um this strikes the the modern liberal
as
bigotry you know because you're making
them feel unwelcome you're making them
feel as lesser than you're making them
feel uh challenged in this environment
and that's that's discrimination that's
that's you know that's it's bad it's not
nice
um
and it makes this work very challenging
because ultimately you have to be able
to
discuss the reality of it you have to be
able to discuss the ideological tenets
directly
and of course this will make people feel
bad of course
but that's the the work of
bringing in a group of people from a
very different part of the world with
very different ideals and integrating
them into our society and making them
equal in our society equal citizens with
the same stake as everybody else that's
a who said that was going to be a
wonderful process that was going to make
everyone feel great
because well the thing that I've always
found very interesting is you have
feminists who obviously that's what they
do they talk and write about women's
rights and how women have been
discriminated against and they talk
about how women are being discriminated
in the west and they pick these tiny
little issues that don't make a
difference either way and they avoid the
topic of Islam when you look at girls so
I taught I've taught in schools as a
when I was a teacher which were majority
Muslim schools and you've seen
six-year-old girls wearing a hijab and
you think
why do they need to do this why is this
but nobody wants to talk about this
publicly and say I I don't agree with
this and this is wrong yeah
it's depressing uh because there there
are consequences to this lack of action
where I think too many countries in
Europe are and when it comes to this
kind of negotiation uh that you should
ideally it should be a negotiation
between the the incoming immigrants and
and the native populations is not a
negotiation at all it's like a hostage
situation
um It's a situation with one side has
all the moral you know and you know even
political uh weight behind it and the
other side feels as if they cannot
challenge it lest they be decried by
others around them as right wing
um and this fear of being right wing is
so much greater than I think what the
sense of unease that everybody feels
about
um seeing a lot of conservative you know
ideals in in practice around them yeah
well Sarah this brings us on to what you
said in the wake of the
Salman Rusty thing because while I think
you're right that a lot of people fear
being smeared or called you know
islamophobic or racist or whatever for
talking about some of these issues I
also think it's very clear now that
there's
a good reason to be fearful in Europe at
least if you speak up about some of
these issues or if you criticize the
faith as you you do that you're likely
to find yourself in danger and the point
that you made in your brilliant article
was that we in the west have become
confused about the source of that
violence and where it comes from because
we think well these people are so
offended by something that's been said
that they are outraged and that's why
they're reacting this way but it's not
true yeah yeah we
we tend to to look at things from this
you know psychological perspective
um where hurting people's self-esteem
we're offending them we're evoking
emotions in them that are unpleasant and
thus they are reacting uh to our
provocation
and and I find that it is
completely missing the point when it
comes to what's going on uh with at
least the more radical fringes of Islam
certainly and I think in fact much of it
much of the problems that we're seeing
um but in the radical fringes they don't
feel offended and even if they do that's
not what's motivating them that's not
why they're moving forward that's not
why they're going to stab you tomorrow
because they're so offended and they
just can't control themselves and
they're you know there's a that's even a
racist idea on some level that you are
so incapable of controlling your
emotions uh that you you can't help but
you know having just burst out of you in
in a fit of violence and and and rage
it's a condescension as well as just a
point-blank misunderstanding so what is
the truth what is it that motivates them
what's motivating them is that they are
they understand their faith as uh
calling on them to defend it when it is
attacked so when somebody is uh is
taking part in an action that is
prohibited by Islam
um extremely prohibited by Islam in the
case of drawing Muhammad
um then they must as dutiful Muslims
they must act
and defend this Faith um that act in the
way that God would want them to act so
it's less of a personal thing and more
of this Cosmic thing of defending this
idea so it's essentially enforcing a
blasphemy law on on the west on on
everyone on everyone on everyone it is a
de facto blasphemy law that the the
entire world is and one on one form or
another
um going through and the and
unfortunately I mean this is and this is
one of the uh trickier elements of it
that you have to be able to just
articulate even though it's so difficult
to articulate that the higher the
percentage of Muslims
in your locality the more
um the more that this D you know this
this blasphemy prohibition becomes
actual de facto law you know
um becomes something that you have to
fear
um when you start talking about this
religion and so I think in America I
have lust of fear than I do in many
other parts of the world I think I've
Leicester fear here than I do in some
parts of Europe
many parts of Europe unfortunately
um and this is also a very it's a I even
feel bad saying it because you're not
supposed to talk about about these
things but realistically of course if
there's more people around you to hear
what you're saying to then interpret
their belief in this very literal way
you're more likely to be in danger and
what about you you've meant you've
mentioned the distinction between the
good Muslims and the extremists let's
say and we've had many people on the
show you know former Al-Qaeda operative
Eamon Dean for example and and others
who've studied this issue a lot who kind
of explained to us that really the
the battle isn't between the west and
Islam it's between islamists and
everybody else and that's why you know
the the stat that people often say is
well the biggest victims of terrorism
Islamic terrorism are Muslims so isn't
that the case that the problem is less
about you know the however many billion
Muslims around the world most of whom
aren't doing anything like this and it's
really about those extremists who are
taking a particular interpretation yeah
isn't that the case
I don't think so no why not I mean I I
hardly ever I mean we've talked about it
just now
um and in my piece with someone Rushdie
I talked about it but in my work on the
whole I hardly ever talk about terrorism
or extremism those radical fringes of it
um I think that they are very helpful in
um radicals in general they're help
they're helpful in getting you to
understand
where a logic might lead but that logic
is still there even if it is not present
and it's very literal extreme form
um it is always there and it's always
still affecting you
um it's still affecting you know the
society in which this logic is prevalent
um and yes so I
it's tough because you don't want to
paint the average Muslim who really
isn't doing anything just wants to go
about their day and you know their lives
might not be putting their children in
you know because so my parents were not
extremists they were quite liberal for
Muslims I was not forced to do or where
um a burqa I was not you know I was
enforced into a marriage or anything I
did have to dress conservatively what
would be conservative considered very
conservatively here I was expected to
eventually have an arranged marriage
um not today not to participate in
certain social habits like drink you
know partying or drinking or any of that
obviously that was prohibited but but my
parents didn't
you know hurt me or harm me or force me
into you know more extremist elements of
the practice so is it fair to then call
these you know good people who are just
their immigrants are working hard every
day trying to give their children a good
life is it fair to say to demonize them
in any way to say that there's something
deeply wrong with their cherished most
cherished beliefs
I get it I get why this is hard to say
why this is hard to talk about
um but it's simply not true that you can
cleave off
extremists from what gives them uh
strength right because extremists
actually you know they
in the case of religious experiments
they're not operating on in a total
vacuum they're not you know and
kidnapped somewhere and brainwashed and
now they're they're coming out they have
grown up their whole lives with a
certain kind of beliefs and those
beliefs are accepted largely within
their Community just not in their
extreme form but the internal logic of
it is accepted so yes you give you give
your life to God you restrict yourself
from these and these behaviors what the
society around you are filled with
disbelievers and people who are going to
hell and they're burning in hell I mean
there's just these General ways of
looking at the world that is in fact
of you shared by every everyone you know
um with the exception of maybe Muslims
who are so extreme that other Muslims
would not call them Muslims like
extremely religious and uh extremely
liberal I mean
um I don't think it
it doesn't make sense to to separate it
wouldn't this be the case with almost
any belief like for example I Believe by
virtue of de facto observation that
there's a difference between men and
women yeah right it doesn't mean I
believe that women should be maltreated
because of it yeah but there are some
people who do yeah so can I not be
cleaved off from them
can I can I can I not be cleaved off
from the people who think men and women
are different therefore women shouldn't
vote
I think you you can and and you can't
right like I mean there's so I I like to
be cleaned up but um
let's say you you have
um so let's let's talk about that
specific example so even I would not
disagree with you there I I too believe
that there are you know differences
between men and women and yet I hold
that there are certain you know legal
equalities that women ought to have
um and that is Justin going to write so
am I by giving them even a little bit of
you know ideological by agreeing with
them even on that perspective am I am I
just agreeing to it all I don't yeah I
understand what you're saying when you
say that there is a difference and I
agree that there is a difference
um but does it make sense to pull it
apart entirely and say that
there is no reason to investigate this
um so when it comes to
let's say women and men what would you
say that the extremists might do with
your belief that women and men are
different they might they might say
women shouldn't vote they might say
women shouldn't vote right right so then
you have to be able to logically make
the case why your slippery slope is in
fact not a slippery slope why that
there's either it's colliding with
another slope that matters to you
another set of values that is also
important
um and there's a good reason why we
shouldn't go down that slippery slope
and you should be able to articulate it
and I'm sure you can actually I'm sure
you can explain to that person why
suffrage of women is important even
though it is true that men and women are
different right so we have to be able to
acknowledge that you share that belief
and you have to be able to explain why
it is why that logic doesn't actually
flow entirely to where they are or maybe
there's another logic that's more
important there's another value another
principle that that clashes with that
and we should listen to to where that's
taking us as well
um but
you can't say no I'm just I'm so
different I don't want what they want
and yes I share this belief but I don't
want what they want and so I don't put
me in the same camp and I shouldn't be
able to I shouldn't be uh uh discussing
this issue in depth and explaining and
articulating my position as well I guess
what I'm saying is this if there are
let's say
1.4 billion people around the world who
believe that men and women are different
and 99 of them
despite recognizing that as a fact don't
believe that women should be
discriminated as a result and one
percent do is it fair to make that
connection or should we say there are
some extremists who also happen to
believe these things I'm not saying it's
a fair argument I'm just curious I don't
even think it's a good argument you know
because it doesn't make sense
it doesn't
um
it doesn't make it doesn't move our
discourse in a direction that is
actually productive because ultimately
you have to be able to explain to the
extremists and persuade them to your
side which means okay we agree on this
yeah but here's why you're wrong yes and
then move them to where you are so if
observably most Muslims are peaceful and
tolerant to to some extent and are able
to live in Western Society
why can we not Target our concerns
specifically of those extremes why does
it have to be about the faith itself
I think because there are some there are
some beliefs that
fundamentally
should be rejected you know there's some
beliefs um so I'm a sec I'm a secularist
I believe I believe deeply that it is
good and right and just and
um
if you have the separation of church and
state
um in a democracy that this is going to
lead to a lot of good outcomes for that
democracy it's going to make the pursuit
of justice and Truth
um easier it's going to lead to a kind
of
civil society that is nice and energetic
and heterodox and so this is an
important Central tenet of my belief if
you disagree with that even a little bit
we have a problem so if you are a
moderate anti-secularist versus an
extreme anti-secularist to me you're
equal you're problematic because
the problem is that you think that there
shouldn't be a separation you know you
think there's just a little separation
or a lot separation that yes there's a
difference there yes that but people are
like your parents they're not trying to
create a caliphate in the United States
I'm trying to kick out caliphates but
they do believe in those values and it
is still important to try and move those
people in a direction that would be
healthier because ultimately communities
are you know they're not it's not tiny
little hot spots of extremists who don't
talk to each other everyone talks to
everyone if you move a certain group
along the Liberals along to you know
closer to where we would want them to be
you move everybody else along
with them like just to some degree
um so I think it is always worth
challenging
so I think Sarah what I'm trying to get
to is I'm trying to understand what
parts of that particular Faith are so
problematic and uh fundamentally
incompatible with the West would you be
able to specify a few things so the
people who are listening and myself
included can understand this yeah I mean
secularism we just we just talked about
that a little bit so there's Islam is a
political idea there's no it makes no
it's nonsensical in Islam to say that
religion should be entirely separate
from the state okay um as it is
traditionally understood
um and that is why there's so many
Muslim majority countries that struggle
with this
um and they have many laws that uh you
know or like um say Bangladesh for
example like they are secularists in
many ways
um they're supposed to be secularists
and yet they have elements of the law in
which they believe you know religious
Authority can have like some say
um like family oriented domestic sort of
things so you sort of see this
um you know whittling away at the edges
of extreme of secularism even in Fairly
you know liberal Muslim you know
democracies
um and in the moderate Muslim World well
it's a lot more it's a religion
pushes in into all aspects of life and
the more most extreme country Saudi
Arabia that are list explicitly we are a
Theocratic State
um there is no freedom of thought there
is no freedom of belief
um
because there are always running against
uh what may or may not be deemed to
blasphemy in in Pakistan for example
I have conversations with
scientists people who are professors you
know talking about geology you know
something that is very physical and real
about the world and they fear their
students
uh
to the extent that what they teach might
go against the Islam it might go against
religious you know understanding of of
the universe they fear that if if if
they talk about this if they teach these
kinds of lessons to their students they
might be accused to blasphemy and so you
see this these societies that are
you know pulled back like held back away
from what we call you know the modern
world uh because their ability to think
openly and freely is just curtailed by
by religion at every level you know even
in very abstract levels of course
artists yes human rights activists women
these are the very explicit examples but
also scientists who are trying to learn
about
the natural world but if you have a
Theocratic State they believe that that
is not true and that what you are
teaching about the natural world is in
fact blasphemy uh and then you're and
then you're under under threat so
there's a there's a a societal wide
effect of the lack of secularism
um and then you get to a society that is
just incapable of
finding truth right so it's incapable of
scientific inquiry Muslim the Muslim
world is one of the worst
um it is now but there was a time when
it was at the very Forefront of science
the Golden Age yeah yeah I mean a lot of
the medical and other things that were
developed in that time we're still used
to this day and algebra and all these
things right yeah
um
so I wouldn't go I won't go too deep
into my
uh theories about uh the Golden Age of
Islam but let's um let's leave it at at
this uh
I think much of what what happened then
um the great achievements of the Muslim
World
um where were allowed you know permitted
because the the people in power the
calebs in power at the time were fairly
liberal
um so this is a kind of a benefit of an
authoritarian state that if you have the
man at the top uh if he happens to be
fairly liberal um and and encourages uh
movement in you know scientific Arena or
whatever and is tolerant to this uh then
you might see progress uh but if he
isn't then you don't
uh and that's that's my theory for what
why you saw something you saw sort of
the spurt you know this of of a lot of
interesting thinking and Innovation
um I think that we're protected by by
the state at that time but of course the
next guy came along and said I don't
believe this and I don't believe you
should be allowed to have these freedoms
and they strip those freedoms away from
them this is why it's important that
those freedoms are
baked in you know there are unmovable in
the way that they are in the United
States
and what was it like being a young girl
and a young woman in the Muslim faith
did you feel that you
that you there were certain things that
were available to men that weren't
available to you were you seen in a
different ways I mean every I mean it's
it's a sexed religion it's a it's a
religion that views the appropriate
place for women in the appropriate place
for meant to be very different
um based on what God says will get you
into heaven you know you behave a
certain way as a woman and you will you
have these duties womanly duties and
then you
duties as a man now
having said all that you know these were
these were these offended me a lot when
I was a young woman who wanted her
Freedom
um and wanted to get to get get away
from uh all these restrictions around
her I felt that I was a person of you
know who had a lot of potential and I
felt like this potential was being
restricted
um by these various restrictions around
me but having having said that I did
when I was a believer
I thought it was right you know I
thought it was God knows more than you
so who am I to question you know who am
I to say that
you know I actually I should be allowed
to
leave as far as I want and dress how I
want who am I to say that I don't I
don't know that I don't I don't have his
his uh his Brilliance I'm not the
Creator I'm not omniscient
um and and I've followed logically that
my own moral intuitions or the you know
the moral beliefs of the society around
me could not be true
simply because there is a God and he has
a message and he tells you what that
message is so you you should follow
so I followed with the logic of that up
until I left religion and that's when it
started to bother me you know that's
when it that's when it chased but it
actually didn't chase before then
because I was I'm a very
I'm I'm not too dissimilar I think from
the kinds of people who end up becoming
jihadis from from the perspective of
let's follow this logic as far as it'll
take us that's comforting
but Sarah what was the moment for you
where you thought
I don't there's something here I I can't
get on board with when was the moment
that you started to have doubt it was
there a particular incident
hmm well I had um
atheists who were my friends I know that
they instigated some of the more
critical examinations that I had faith I
always I was always a questioning person
so I always questioned the edges of it
um but the edges of it are you know
they're more flexible in the sense that
it could be that there's something some
human interpretation that went wrong
along the way or my teacher is wrong
specifically and what he's teaching me
um
I was always questioning
um but the I never questioned the
fundamental idea that there may not be a
God and I literally didn't never
conceived of such a thing until I met
some atheists and these were you know
young men who had just left religion
themselves so they were they were in
their uh anti-antitheist phase kind of
like the Reddit atheist kind of
phase
um and so they they thought it was very
important to expose me to the criticisms
they had of of Islam I remember once I
got one of my friends gave me a list
of verses from the Quran and he said
explain these you know like explain
these these verses he made he made the
effort of like printing something out it
was
uh and then I remember thinking it will
be explained in context
which is it's sort of the standard
religious
initial response anyway because I did
believe it would be explained in context
of course it would be my religion was
right and it was true and you know it
was the right understanding of the world
and I
um and then I went and read about the
context and the context made it worse
so that that caused uh me to you know
really start to look into
uh faith in a more critical Manner and I
it was interesting because I always had
a critical appraisal of Christianity I
you know here's why we cannot uh you
know trust that the gospels are are you
know true because they've been
translated whatever all this stuff and
and here here all these criticisms I
have about the historosity of Jesus
and and there was a moment where
suddenly my brain said okay let's just
apply all of these criticisms to to
Islam and that it just all fell down
like a like a house of cards and so what
then was the next step because a lot of
people will take your journey and then
they go well I no longer want to
practice a faith I want to leave the
faith I know people who have left Islam
and they get on with their own lives and
they're fine what made you want to
become an activist and talk about a
subject like this one which could put
you in very real physical Danger
um I think there's something wrong with
me
psychologically you know there's like a
there's a
something that should be plugged in that
isn't or something something's missing
something's different
um
but I've always been kind of a
proselytizer in one form or another you
know when I was Muslim I wanted to save
my Christian friends so I shared with
them you know the the logic of Islam and
and why the Trinity made no sense and
you you know and and we would have all
these like conversations and if this is
like we're 12 and we're running a mile
in gym class and we're having these like
discussions about deep theological
discussions of course nobody knew what
they were talking about I I was
proselytizing then and then when I let
when I left the faith it just it was of
course logical for me to continue on
um
proselytizing to some degree but
I was fine myself my family was tolerant
enough that I was able to go to college
I was able to move away I was slowly
freeing myself from uh the kinds of
restrictions that I grew up with
um distancing myself from some parts of
the family of course who were not happy
and kind of living a double life in a
way a lot of ex-muslims live but I was
Finding
in my own personal space I was finding
some peace and I was finding that I
could I could live the way I wanted to
live
um
it was it was when we started to you
know form what were what were the
beginnings of the organization uh
initially just social meetups of
ex-muslims and this was a very
scary thing especially to do in that
time you're pulling in random people on
the internet you don't know them they
could be they could be here to kill you
you know and you had to sort of trust
that they were you know have screenings
you call them talk to them trying to get
a you know engage on who they are meet
in a very public place
um it was a very risky thing to do uh we
started to have these like social social
events and
I would have people driving over from
like six hours away one way to have a
two-hour happy hour
and then you know it had a hotel for the
night they would stay the night and then
drive back it was so much effort for for
what was just like a brief you know
brief interaction and I
started to recognize as I talked to them
that this was such an important you know
reprieve from the lives that they were
forced to live and I was you know to use
a word that I otherwise don't like if it
was very privileged in my experience
and with that privilege like comes to
certain I think it's there comes a
responsibility to do something about it
and make the world at least as good for
them as it was for me
um
in comparison right and so that that
made me think that we need to do
something and and and address the
problem at its root insofar as we could
or at least loosen things a little bit
um to give people enough reprieve to
live their lives
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
and Sarah what advice would you give
someone who mate was in the cinema
situation that you are or perhaps in a
more conservative family and they want
to leave the faith what what should they
do how should they go about doing it
uh I mean I think it depends on their
family but I would say that if they're a
young person they need to establish
Financial Independence you know first
and foremost
um they need to have that in the bag
they need to be making their own money
they need to be able to live their own
lives away from the family control
um if a family has that over them then
they have everything
um and they can force you to do what you
want
um so that that's very important for
people who have
immigration and their immigration status
is based on their parents wait until you
have you know citizenship wait till you
have permanent residency you don't rely
on that anymore
um and then you know ask questions I
think asking questions helps a lot
um
the way that I went about it with my
parents was not
I didn't tell them all at once I shared
my questions as I had them and they
themselves struggled with answering the
questions and so by the end of the
journey they sort of understood you know
okay okay you know
um because I understood where I
the intellectual difficulties that I was
having and they were less worried that I
was just leaving religion because I
wanted to party and drink and you know
strip or whatever it is
going to do
um uh Sarah I can we do we have one more
go at the whole extremist versus I'm
just I'm trying to work it out because
here's I'll tell you from a personal
background right I grew up in in in the
former Soviet Union and for a part of my
life I lived in Uzbekistan
which is a Muslim country
how long uh I was there for four years
my father was born there and lived there
most of his life and neither him or I
Muslims
but the way that the faith is practiced
there is completely different to the way
that it might be practiced against uh
not against the way it might be
practiced in Britain where we live now
by by Muslims who are far more
conservative I get the sense about the
way that they apply it
so I'm just trying to disentangle it
because for me
it's I
cringe when people say Islam is a
religion of Peace immediately after a
terrorist attack I also cringe when
people imply that that means Islam is a
religion of violence because I just
think there's such a massive gap between
those two extreme positions in the
Middle where most Muslims will actually
fit right right yeah
so
but what I'm hearing from what you were
talking about is that Islam is kind of
the problem the faith itself is the
problem aspects of the faith are are
definitely the problem yes
um and there have to be loosened in one
way or the other
um to be able to change so for let's go
back to your example with Uzbekistan
Soviet country yeah Soviet countries if
you if you look at like um
social views of Muslims you know there's
like various polls like pupils and
galpels whatever random random polls
about uh
social views that Muslims might have
women how much they should be covered
homosexuality how should we punish that
kind of thing
and they find consistently that that
that the Soviet the former Soviet block
is which is now
you know majority Muslim is far more
liberal in their Outlook right
um
and this makes sense
liberal but it's more liberal yeah right
but it's quite consistent with
non-muslim countries in the former
Soviet Union so they kind of had similar
values so their attitudes to
homosexuality are not that different to
people in Armenia which is a Christian
country right but still very different
to America or Britain right so one way
to think about it might be if you have
competing ideologies uh one can soften
the blow of the other if they if if and
when they conflict
that happens to you know Muslims who are
very westernized that might happen like
if you've raised in the west you've
lived around liberals all your life your
parents are liberals too you have this
sort of
um
you have this
secular morality that you have absorbed
by osmosis like Through Your Skin
um and you believe it to be true
and then you have this religious
ideology as well that's sort of saying
some different things so then you have
to find ways for that to for the
conflict to resolve
um in one way or the other
or you go in One Direction or the other
um so often you see you'll hear stories
of people who are extremists that you
know were provoked into looking deeper
into their religion
and they they went in they started
reading the text and they become you
know jihadis or they become ex-muslims
you know or they leave they have that
sense of like okay this can't be
resolved in fact
um the average person can actually live
with a good deal of cognitive dissonance
yes you know I think we um we know this
um so I think that
in my opinion you know
it is really important to be able to
introduce competing values and advocate
for them strongly and convince them
about those values about the the the
value of those values like um the the
benefit of of you know approaching those
values why they might be good
inherently that process introduces a
level of doubt in your faith
um I like to think about it in the sense
of
I have Catholic friends who are fairly
religious
and they might say
uh strange things were to me strange
when I first started they might say
things like I'm a Catholic but
I think gay marriage is you know fine or
I think you know some abortion should be
okay in some contexts you start you hear
that thing you're right with Christians
quite often this I'm a Christian but
yeah yeah what that butt implies is that
I believe in my faith
I think it is
important and I think it is probably
true
but it is possible in my mind that it is
not 100 the truth or that it is possible
it is possible in my mind that you can
reach the truth some other way that you
can reach Morality In some other way
it implies a level of doubt in in your
own in your own belief just a little it
doesn't have to be a lot just a little
enough to make room for something else
to come in and make a claim
you know just a kernel of Doubt is all
you need
if you don't have any doubt you're an
extremist you're never gonna go you're
never gonna say I'm a Christian but
you're never gonna utter those words
they make no sense why would but what
you know there is a right way to behave
there's a right value system there's a
correct way to be no buts
um I think what
the Muslim world needs is just that
kernel of doubt
the Soviet Bloc has that Chrome moved
out partially because they stamped it
into them
um but I think insofar as we can
introduce it that makes a massive
difference in the behavior of
individuals
just
um looking at it from Just extremists
Alone
um
you have to be
oh you have to be convinced that your
way of life is 100 true that the Quran
is 100 the word of God
if you're about to kill somebody it
takes certainty you know if you're a
rational person it takes certainty
what if you just 99 true you know just
so yes probably in all likelihood
maybe not that's that's enough certain
uncertainty that you don't slit
somebody's throat right and that's a
very crucial very important difference
when it comes to living together in the
Democracy that violence is suddenly
something that
is
you know something that you can't you
can't you can no longer justify given
your level of of certainty so I think
maybe thinking Less in terms of moderate
Muslim extremist Muslim you know liberal
Muslim and More in terms of
um how pluralistic is there is there
belief you know how how certain are they
in the correctness of of their belief
versus anyone else's
and Sir let's wrap this up in a slightly
interesting way because you mentioned
being an atheist I when I was probably
18 20 that I found that way of thinking
very appealing now I'm agnostic and I
think that's likely where I'm gonna stay
but I you hear a lot of people talk
about the fact that
and I have some sympathy with this
argument that the
decreasing religiousness of the West has
allowed things like wokeness to step
into that void what do you as an atheist
make of that argument I think it's a
interesting argument and um makes me
very uncomfortable I can imagine but um
but yeah I think there's um
it's fascinating and
adds a complication to
you know what I would as an atheist
prefer to to think and and be true about
the world and human nature really
um and how we optimize for the best kind
of society
I would
prefer that a society in which no
there's no religion
um
you know and also somehow we have solved
for Dogma you know the Dogma that might
come in other forms
um I think that's the best Society of
all sure but is that a song is that a is
that a possible Right Society probably
not um is it is it possible for us to
not have religious Dogma
um and to also somehow restrict uh
resist every other kind of Dogma
um is that a possible World
um so from that perspective you know uh
a a
secular but religious does that make
sense yeah the world is
in some ways worse you know the worst of
all you know possible outcomes you know
maybe maybe even as bad as ancient you
know religious contexts
um yeah so that's I I I I think that's a
very interesting train of thought I I'm
not sure where I end up there
at the moment
I do think that there is um
psychological need I think for the
comfort of some kind of transcendental
values you know I think they can be
routed in other ways I don't think you
need God but I think you need them to be
bigger than you
um and you need it to be something that
draws you into the collective and to
people around you and something that
gives you this sense of belonging and
personal significance but also
and this is a word that never doesn't
get used enough Duty towards others you
know like not just that I belong here
and you make me feel great and
personally significant that's that's
wonderful but also what do you owe them
what do you owe your fellow man
um I think that's that
idea of Duty is what is a Cornerstone of
communities you know and we're seeing
the fraying of communities
on you and I isn't that this our fault a
little bit maybe yeah
um insofar as we can't find something
else
um insofar as that we can't address this
problem in some other creative way but
ultimately I think this is where
modernity is going
um
uh this is what you know this is the
path that we're walking down
um sort of alienation from each other
from physical the you know the physical
world from uh broader uh you know the
world around us our neighbors that kind
of thing we're increasingly alienated
from and that's a modernity challenge
can you bring religion back and say that
this is the so this is the solution I
don't know I don't know if you can force
yourself to believe something that is
you know
not true I don't think I could I think
that even if I thought religion was very
good I don't think I could go back to it
well this is where I am because
I think really I know and have
experiences of knowing that religion not
Islam actually but Christianity some
forms of Christianity can be very bad
and Islam clearly there are some forms
of that or some people who follow it who
can be very bad
but the Level Society I look around and
I'm kind of going
[Music]
there was you said it yourself you need
something that's above you you need
something that connects you to other
people you need the community in a world
that's becoming increasingly detached
from in which we've become detached from
each other
I don't know that we've come up with
yeah an alternative work people have
and I'm like you know what I I'd rather
be an Anglican if that's the choice
anglicanism works for me compared to
this crap but that's not really a
religion anymore is it well it's you
know let's not get into that we have
five minutes left or whatever you know
what I mean yeah so so how can we
advocate for or not Advocate but how can
we say well you know agnosticism is good
or being an atheist is good when we look
around and we go the Practical
consequences of the lack of religion are
bad
um yeah I wouldn't say that it's exactly
the Practical consequences of a lack of
religion I think they're all uh
that the lack of religion and the the uh
incidents more more wokeism in the world
or more sensitive alienation they're all
being caused by another Factor you know
that's happening together that that is
it seems to me that there's nothing we
can really do about with the tools that
we have at our
at our disposal at the moment you mean
technology
technology has a big role to play in the
overall alienation that we feel
um and the various social consequences I
mean you can't even use you think of the
social fabric it doesn't even make sense
to think of it as a fabric it's not a
fabric where individual threads floating
around and we're knotted up in one piece
or another in one online community or
space and and and uh isolated there
um
I think the problem is a bigger one and
I don't know if old religion has the
tools to solve it partially because well
it makes a lot of claims about the real
world and they they have an effect
um not a good one and it is hard to get
the you know a 17 year old to believe in
the the literal truth of of something
that's making claims that are not true
in the natural world and we know for a
fact and they know for a fact you can't
hide this from them anymore so the ways
in which uh religion is literally not
true is a hurdled and I don't know if it
can overcome
um insofar as we're we're considering
what is a solution
to you really I mean that's the so
that's that what the solution is what
would it be that would change you well
we've been sitting so our friends who
were staying with here they're they're
Christians and we've been we've spent
every night sitting right around here
arguing this back and forth and there's
not they haven't they're very clever
people yeah and I respect them very much
but they there's nothing that can
convince me
of that but on the other hand
I am extremely convinced that without
Community without connection which they
have because if you're a Christian you
go to church you have a community the
way you relate to other people is
different and so on
you know without that human beings are
not designed to live in this world that
we live in now when we're not designed
we didn't evolve sorry triggering words
we did not evolve to live alone to live
in disconnected disembodied life
um and so I feel it's you know
particularly I became a father recently
I'm thinking about this like what are we
offering people
because this disembodied disconnected
existence is not good for us no no
way at
[Music]
element of human existence like I mean
not to be too too grandiose about it but
I think it's true that um
relationships you know sex people are
having sex people aren't happy people
don't have friendships people are
isolated and Alone
um uh and plugged into these digital
spaces that are very toxic and damaging
to them uh they are encouraged to
conceive of themselves as
as the end product right as the pitcher
at the end that you post on your profile
um and in the video that you take of
yourself is almost a performer first
um and to think about yourself in third
person
um all the time and to be signaling all
the time it's a very it's an exhausting
way to live and I think it's a it's not
it's not a surprise to me that
Zoomers are you know they're just
up they're they're you know they're
they're having they have a lot of
problems
um and it seems like not a lot of
solutions
I don't have an answer for you and I
just don't think that
it would be nice maybe if we can have a
nice form of Christianity
can we though can we you know pass that
on to a 13 year old that has access to
the internet and finds Reddit atheism
and and they're all like this is why
it's wrong and then you stop believing
right
um so long as we don't have a choice in
the matter of belief or not belief
it is important that they are making
literal claims about the world that are
not not true
um and I think we'll
affect their the ability of an even a
nice Christianity to go very far
um in moving people and pulling them
away from uh from the disconnectedness
that we're seeing around us there has to
be some other solution but I you know I
I was in charge of creating communities
when I was you know in running my
organization and it was a very
interesting experience in that
I recognized how religion is very useful
at committing good and healthy
communities in fact you know in the
religious communities are demonized
um a lot sometimes fairly I think
oftentimes fairly and then sometimes
unfairly you said there's some benefits
to to that form of organization
um and it provides benefits to the
people to the members of that Community
um and it's hard to replicate that
um without these kinds of values
um tying you together yeah so I think
that's going to be a challenge
um but you know um to end on a kind of
an optimistic note I think human beings
are very adaptable
and yes technology is throwing a lot of
problems at us very quickly which makes
things difficult to make it's difficult
for us I think to adapt quickly
um
but it is very possible that we do it's
very possible that we come you know
immune to the kind of siren songs of of
social media and like the online world
and find a way back to something a
little bit more healthy Sarah it's been
a wonderful interview thank you so much
for coming on the show we always end the
show in the same way which is what is
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that we really should be hmm
well um I Don't Want To Tread too much
ground that we have tread already
um so I will say
I think we should be thinking a lot more
about
the ways in which the Sexes are
different you know I think we should be
uh
more thoughtfully considering
uh how those differences impact us on
our in our day-to-day lives and how
they're impacting our institutions and
our you know social organization as
women become very much a part of them of
these organizations and institutions
sometimes running them you know
sometimes uh becoming the majorities of
you know in in a workplace or in a field
or you know in in an organization so we
should be thinking about
what that changes if anything
um whether that's a good thing whether
we want to resist it somewhat in some
way but people have a hard time even
imagining that
something could be different
that to imply that
you know let's say oh you know the
American
culture not let's say Academia is
entirely 90 women
um
let's say the legislature is 90 women
um people have a people don't like
people don't like it when I say that
this will probably have an effect
on the kind on the institutional Norms
on the way the the psychology behind
which you know those those Norms are
based and they will create new norms and
they will uh behave differently than
they have before and those institutions
function well
in a time and place where men were
predominant in the public space in the
public sphere and that's that's how they
were developed and they functioned well
in that in that space
now that that's changing and you have a
different kind of person with a
different kind of psychology different
kind of way of socializing
um how does that change things and how
do we need to correct for it so you know
to give a specific example you know free
speech on campus right like it's a it's
a woke problem it's a whatever problem
but it's also a problem of you know uh
you have
a you know majority female students in
most campuses
um you have high percentages of of
female faculty and especially in
administration a very high percentage of
it
um and I think that that's the sort of
underground you know uh we talk about
the ideology of vocalism the ideology
behind you know Free Speech Norms you
know sort of disappearing in these
places but there's also just like social
Tendencies of women that are different
than the social Tendencies of men so men
are like yeah let's bet let's duke it
out let's fight let's offend each other
let's
um you know
Battle of the wits or whatever and
somebody's crowned to Victor and there's
a hierarchy and I'm at top and you're at
the bottom now because you're a loser
and then there's the the female way of
socializing which is different you know
it's it's it's more compassionate it's
more oriented around around uh
maintenance of feelings and uh equality
and fairness that those though that kind
of orientation
will have effects when broadly applied
um when you have you know 20 of women in
an institution might not change anything
because they just they do what the men
are doing to dominate in that
environment
um or just survive survive in it uh then
maybe you have 50 50 and things are a
little bit different you know and then
maybe you have 60 40 and now you have
majority women
now women can you know socialize in
their preferred manner
um and the Norms of that institution
shift
so I think that you know that's just
sort of
the way that I think we need to be
thinking about this in a much in a much
more Deep Way than than we have been
instead of just uh sort of whittling
away at the edges of there's not enough
women here there's too many men there or
what Sarah's saying is the women are
coming and they're going to ruin
everything
Sarah if people want to follow your work
I know you have a sub stack where else
should people go to find you yeah I have
a sub stack called hold that thought
um or you could just type in Sarah
hater.substack.com and you'll find my my
writings there I talk I write a lot
about you know sex now and gender which
is getting me into a lot of trouble
um and we need to discuss here
thankfully uh but there's next time next
time maybe yeah there's so there's a lot
of that on my sub stack you can also
find me
um wasting my time on Twitter it's my
handle is Sarah the hater
so you can reach me there as well all
right perfect well thank you so much for
coming on uh and join us on locals where
we're going to ask Sarah a few of your
questions that only those of you who are
on locals will get to see the answers to
take care and see you soon
have you found that people have left one
Faith are more likely to have doubts
about Progressive ideologies
[Music]